the function f of x is graphed what is
its domain so the way it's graphed right
over here we could assume that this is
the entire function definition for f of
x so for example if we say well what
does f of x equal when x is equal to
negative nine well we go up here we
don't see it's graphed here it's not
defined for x equals negative nine or x
equals negative eight and a half or x
equals negative eight it's not defined
for any of these values it only starts
getting defined at x equals negative six
at x equals negative six f of x is equal
to five and then it keeps getting
defined f of x is defined for x all the
way from x equals negative six all the
way to x equals seven when x equals
seven f of x is equal to five you can
take any x value between negative 6
including negative 6 and positive 7
including positive 7 and you just have
to see to you just have to move up above
that number wherever you are to find out
where that what the value of the
function is at that point
so the domain of this of this function
definition well x is f of x is defined
for any x that is greater than or equal
to negative 6 or we could say negative 6
is less than or equal to x which is less
than or equal to 7. if x satisfies this
condition right over here the function
is defined so that's its domain so let's
check our answer let's do a few more of
these
the function f of x is graphed what is
its domain well
exact similar argument this function is
not defined for x is negative 9 negative
8 all the way down or all the way up i
should say to negative 1. at negative 1
we it starts getting defined f of
negative 1 is negative 5.
so it's defined for negative 1 is less
than or equal to x and it's defined all
the way up to x equals 7 including x
equals 7. so this right over here
negative 1 is less than or equal to x is
less than or equal to seven the function
is defined for any x that satisfies this
this this double inequality right over
here let's do a few more
the function f of x is graphed what is
its range so now we're not thinking
about the x's for which this function is
defined we're thinking about the set of
y values what is where where do all of
the y values fall into
well let's see the lowest possible y
value or the lowest possible value of f
of x that we get here
looks like it's zero the function never
goes below zero
so f of x so zero is less than or equal
to f of x it does equal zero right over
here f of negative four is zero and then
the highest y value or the highest value
that f of x obtains in this function
definition is eight f of seven is eight
it never gets above eight but it does
equal eight right over here at when x is
equal to seven so 0 is less than f x
which is less than or equal to
8. so that's its range
let's do a few more this is kind of fun
the function f of x is graphed what is
its domain so once again this function
is defined for
negative 2
negative 2
is less than or equal to x which is less
than or equal to 5. if you give me an x
anywhere in between negative 2 and 5 i
can look at this graph to see where the
function is defined f of negative two is
negative four f of
negative one is negative three so on and
so forth and i can even pick the values
in between these integers so negative
two is less than or equal to x which is
less than or equal to
five